we've spent more hours than we'd care to
count adventuring in various open World
Games over the years and we're gearing
up to do it all over again as there are
plenty on the horizon here's gamespot's
list of the 25 biggest upcoming open
world games to look forward to in 2023
and Beyond
breath of the wild redefines not only
what a Legend of Zelda game could be but
also rewrote the blueprints for open
World Games in general its sequel tears
of the Kingdom will take Link into the
Skies of Hyrule give him new time
reversal powers and a resurrected threat
to face Suicide Squad kill the Justice
League is the latest from Rocksteady the
studio best known for the incredible
Batman Arkham series it's super villains
vs superheroes as the game puts you and
three friends into the shoes of task
force x and plonks you in the middle of
an open world Metropolis to take out the
brainwashed Justice League the game will
feature the last performance of Kevin
Conroy who's been the iconic voice of
Batman for 30 years while not strictly
fully open world Final Fantasy 16 will
offer players huge open areas to explore
in the latest in the long-running
Beloved jrpg series as Clive it's up to
you and your party to investigate the
disruption of power in the land and to
go on a long quest for Revenge after an
attack much has been made of the game's
development team which features naoki
Yoshida AKA Yoshi P who directs the
incredibly successful MMORPG Final
Fantasy 14 cyberpunk 2077 might not have
gotten off to the best start when it
launched in 2020 but CD projekt Red's
futuristic RPG has been on a Redemption
Arc recently with patches that have
fixed a lot of lingering bugs new
content and a fantastic Netflix series
from Studio trigger that Redemption Arc
continues with a new paid expansion for
the game coming in 2023 Phantom Liberty
will be set in an all-new District
within night City and not only will
Keanu Reeves return to voice Johnny
silverhand but he'll be teaming up with
Solomon Reed played by Idris Elba the
Spy Thriller expansion is set to launch
in 2023 but only for the PC Xbox series
and PS5 versions of the game satellite
support has ended for PS4 and Xbox One
owners there's plenty more cyberpunk to
get excited about cdpr has firm that
another full game is in production
details are currently scarce but it's
codenamed Orion and Promises to take the
franchise further and to continue to
harness the potential of this dark
future universe and if you're jonesing
for another Witcher game after jumping
back into the series with the Next Gen
update for The Witcher 3 wild Hunt then
there's good news for you plenty more
are coming but details are thin on the
ground the first game is codenamed
Polaris and is the next Witcher game
it's currently in pre-production and is
the start of a new Trilogy of games
there's also Canis Majoris described as
a full-fledged Witcher game separate to
the new Witcher Saga it will be
developed by an external Studio headed
up by a team who have previously worked
on the series finally there's Sirius and
multiplayer and single player experience
created by a studio called the Molasses
Flood but it's unclear if that one will
be an open world game Dead Island 2 is
the long-awaited sequel to 2011's Dead
Island taking place in a zombie infested
Los Angeles where it's up to the player
to scrounge for resources craft some
wacky weapons and take out anything that
stands in their path recent
presentations even showed off players
able to channel the power of the undead
after being bit whether playing alone or
in co-op with friends the zombies of
hellae don't stand a chance for spoken
is an upcoming open world game from
Square Enix that'll put you in the shoes
of Frey Holland a New Yorker who was
somehow transported to the Mysterious
World of athia where she develops
magical powers and befriends a sentient
bracelet named cuff use your powers to
easily Traverse the vast open world or
to take out the beasts that call it home
there's a demo out now if you fancy
giving it a go since its 2017
announcement we've been eagerly waiting
to take to the high seas in Skull and
Bones a pirate open world game from
Ubisoft born from the naval Warfare
sections featured in Assassin's Creed 3
and Black Flag after many many delays
changes in leadership and even redesigns
it's finally set to release in 2023
Avatar fans have a lot to be excited
about after the release of the way of
water comes a new game from Ubisoft
Avatar frontiers of Pandora the first
person action adventure that takes place
in the lush world of Pandora you'll be
facing off against the invading RDA
forces and exploring the world in ways
you never have before the highly
anticipated sequel to 2017's Marvel
Spider-Man is coming sooner than
expected with PlayStation revealing that
Spider-Man 2 will launch in Fall 2023.
we've only seen a brief teaser so far
but the game seems to be setting up
Peter Parker and Miles Morales taking on
Venom we can't wait to swing around New
York City once again and see what the
game has in store for us redfall is the
latest game from prey and Dishonored
developer Arcane Austin and in a huge
departure from the single-player
immersive Sims the team is known for
redfall is an open world Co-op shooter
that you can play solo or with three
friends the town of red for
Massachusetts has a vampire problem and
is one of four survivors with while
healthy different abilities it's up to
you to take them out the long dormant
stalker series is coming back with
stalker 2. originally planned for a
December 2022 release the game was
delayed due to the Russian invasion of
Ukraine where the development team is
based the game doesn't have a new
confirmed release date just yet but the
post-apocalyptic title will come to PC
and Xbox first launching Day One on Game
Pass and speaking of Game Pass another
huge Day One release for the service
will be Starfield Bethesda game studios
first new IP in over 25 years helmed by
famed Fallout 3 and Elder Scrolls
director Todd Howard create your
character join factions make friends and
enemies and explore a thousand planets
outside of our solar system in Bethesda
game studios biggest game yet set in the
pillars of Eternity Universe a vowed is
an upcoming first person open world game
from the team at Obsidian Entertainment
and that's pretty much all we know about
it other than we know we'll be able to
use magic as well as Weapons like swords
in a system that seems very similar to
The Elder Scrolls 5 Skyrim and speaking
of the Elder Scrolls the sequel to
Skyrim is officially in the works at
Bethesda game studios but it seems like
it'll be a while before we can play it
after all this team has to ship
Starfield first announced back in 2018
with a brief and I mean brief teaser the
team at Bethesda has only offered slight
hints about when we can expect the eagly
anticipated sequel to the cultural
phenomenon that is Skyrim and turns out
it won't be for another couple of years
at least while we wait I guess we can
take another swing at Skyrim now that
it's out on pretty much every platform
going Doki V is the upcoming open world
monster collector and battler from Pearl
Abyss who are best known for the MMO
Black Desert online we don't know much
about Doki V but it debuted with a
colorful music video at gamescom's
Opening Night Live in 2021 and while
we're talking about Pearl Abyss the team
has another open world game in the works
Crimson desert takes place on a war-torn
continent and according to the
developers your decisions and actions
will Direct directly influence the story
Crimson desert will be full of
exploration mystery and of course combat
some of which even takes place in the
skies atomic heart from Mund fish and
focus entertainment is a first person
shooter reminiscent of Bioshock with
players able to mix and match weapons
and powers like electricity and
telekinesis to rip through anything that
stands in their way the game is also
scored by Mick Gordon The Man Behind the
face meltingly great Doom 2016
soundtrack rise of the Ronin is a brand
new action game from Team ninja the
studio behind Neo and Ninja Gaiden it's
an open world RPG set in the late 19th
century in Japan and if previous team
ninja games are anything to go by combat
will be incredibly important and
probably very difficult it's set to
launch in 2024 and will be a PlayStation
console exclusive at the 2022 game
awards hideo Kojima took to the stage to
reveal a sequel to 2019's hit death
stranding with death stranding Kojima
and his team created a new genre aiming
at Connecting People which was oddly
prescient given the impact of the
pandemic which happened a few months
later the sequel is set to bring back a
lot of faces from the original game
including Leia saidu's fragile and
Norman Reedus as Sam Porter Bridges
Contraband is an upcoming Co-op
Smuggler's Paradise from Avalanche
Studios the team behind the just cause
series we don't know much about the game
just yet other than it's set in the
1970s in the fictual world of Bayan and
it's an Xbox console exclusive Dragon's
Dogma was a cult hit when it was
released in 2012. it was a fun take on a
traditional open world fantasy RPG and
gave the player pawns which are AI
controlled party members that could be
shared online with other players a
sequel is being developed using capcom's
re engine which the company is using for
the Resident Evil remix and used on
Devil May Cry 5. it's hard to believe
it's almost been 10 years since the
launch of Dragon Age Inquisition but
we're finally finally getting a sequel
in Dragon Age dread wolf one that sets
to put everyone's beloved egg Mage Solas
firmly into the role of antagonist
there's no release date for dread wolf
just yet but the game recently completed
its Alpha Milestone and is completely
playable from beginning to end
Inquisition wasn't strictly an open
world game and there's no guarantee that
dread wolf will be one but if the amount
of time I spent in the Hinterlands
counts for anything then it is an
honorary open world game a new Fable was
confirmed to be in development back in
2020 but since then we've barely heard
anything about it the Beloved uniquely
British franchise has been dormant at
Xbox for a number of years but now it's
being rebooted by playground games who
you may know as the team responsible for
Forza Horizon so there you have it 25
upcoming open world games that are set
to launch in 2023 and Beyond to keep up
to date on all of them make sure to
subscribe to Gamespot on YouTube or
check out gamespot.com I'm on Twitter at
Lucy James games and I'll see you next
time